so my barbie story is
interesting and complicated because as a
kid i wanted a barbie doll so badly and
my mother did not allow me to have one
and
it was painful
and i was shamed because i wanted a
barbie
but i would
somehow i got to play jax as a kid so i
made my own doll so i would take fabric
and i would um
fray the fabric and create hair and then
i would take the ball of the um from jax
and then i would put like a stick in and
i would like put you know um
the hair into the um
ball jack ball that you used for jacks
you could kind of like take a pin or um
and like pushed the hair into it so i
like made my own dolls as a kid and they
would fly and she had superpowers
and um
and probably about 15
18 years ago i was in therapy
and i told my therapist that story and
it was really painful and traumatizing
and um my therapist said it's never too
late to have a happy childhood you have
a little child who lives inside you
right now so you should go and buy
yourself a barbie and play with her
[Music]
and so i did
i went out and bought a barbie doll and
i played with her and i addressed her
and um it was a way for me to heal my my
inner child
and um
and i told my mother
that my therapist who suggested this
um
and
it was a part of my healing process and
recovering from childhood trauma
and then my mother that christmas sent
me a barbie doll
it's incredibly meaningful for me to
have my own barbie doll for so many
reasons and i hope that
i hope that parents out there who may be
seeing this
and their kid wants to play with barbie
no matter what gender they were assigned
to birth that they say like yay
you can go and do that it's cool here
played with the laverne barbie um i hope
that kids
of all gender identities can look at
this barbie and and dream
they think that like the space of
dreaming
and manifesting is when you lose that it
it is
so deeply painful what i've been so
grateful for
throughout my life is that i still dream
there's a kid that is still
living inside me who's very alive and
well who still dreams and whose dreams
big
and imagines a world that is different
and better
the space of play playing with dolls the
space of creating worlds with dolls it's
like this space of dreaming
and
now
kids get to dream with a laverne cox
barbie the first
transgender
barbie um
that is a beautiful space of dreaming
and possibility